the broadcast is now starting all
attendees are in listen only mode good
morning everybody um welcome to today's
presentation on advanced techniques for
order flow trading and again you know
shout out to
the people at investors
expos you know for setting this all up
and you know i'm i'm always excited to
do these um presentations for you guys
because you know the market is so
dynamic and you know as we saw you know
just today and and yesterday um you know
the fed raised rates you know 50 basis
points as expected the market rallied
but today it's all crashing back down to
to reality and
you know some people will get
discouraged thinking oh my gosh you know
the market is is rigged or you know
they're out there to steal your money
well that's not really the case right i
mean markets move based off of people's
perceptions of
what's going to be happening in the
future and what happened yesterday and
what's happening today is is a perfect
example and so today what i'll be um
explaining you know and i'll be using
today and yesterday as examples
is
how to trade with the big players and
profit from their moves you know because
you know at the end of the day
the people that
move the markets you know are the big
players right they
have the money behind them to
you know buy or sell which you know then
builds on itself and you know markets
will go up or the markets will go down
and i'm going to teach you how to learn
i'm sorry how to
read market sentiment so you can
anticipate those price changes right
it's not always about
you know just following along you know
you get to this point where
based on what you're seeing in the
market you know you've you've seen it
over and over you know markets are
fractal um
and
you just see that what looks like the
exact same
pattern or set exact same buying
pressure selling pressure in the market
over and over and you know you're going
to learn how to see that because you
after you start seeing that you're going
to learn how to anticipate when price is
going to move up or move down and you
know it's a bit like driving a car right
the first time you you get behind the
wheel of the car you don't know you know
the flow of traffic or anything you're
not used to it but as you drive more and
more you become used to reading the flow
of traffic right and knowing when to
stay in your lane knowing when to pass
the car in front of you and
you know avoiding accidents and that's
the same thing when it comes to trading
and
the important thing about trading is you
have to stay ahead of your competitors
by knowing what's happening right now in
the market because you know at the end
of the day
what's happening right now this instance
is more important than what happened
yesterday right you saw for example
yesterday with the fed announcement you
know
everyone was expecting the fed to
to do it and they did it okay but then
once they did it
everyone's perception starts changing i
mean it's one thing to think they're
going to do it you know it's like asking
a girl out oh yeah you know you sit
there and you think i'm going to ask
this girl out she's going to say yes but
then you never do it right and and the
same thing um you know with the market
you know people like to sit there and
arm chair quarterback you know everyone
is
is an expert nowadays you know in the
days of social media everyone thinks
they know what's what's what's right and
what's wrong but when you're in the heat
of the moment
that's when you gotta make decisions and
the best way to make decisions is by
gaining an edge over the other traders
in the market and last thing i identify
i'm going to show you guys a high
probability trading setup that you could
use
basically today or tomorrow you know if
you have it on your software a lot of
trading software out there has what i'm
going to teach you um and if not i'm
going to show you where you can get it
from and you know as a special treat if
you stick to the end i'm going to show
you how to get a copy of my book trading
order flow
and you know this is a book that i wrote
several years ago about 2015. it feels
like several years ago but it's you know
it's you'll get the pdf you're not gonna
get a hardcover
copy and you know it talks about order
flow and trading in general it's a great
read
and you know it's sort of one of my
contributions back to the trading world
so those of you that are new to one of
my presentations just a quick brief on
who i am
my name is michael baltos and i've been
in the futures trading industry for over
25 years you know i started on the cme
floor
with dean witter i started as a runner
right which is the the lowest level that
you can start off in
the futures industry i mean nowadays we
don't have those we don't have a trading
floor so you can't start off as a runner
now unfortunately to start in the
business
you have to have like a college degree
with a certain background you know in
programming or in mathematics
but
not everybody does however the nice
thing is the barrier to entry to be to
trading for yourself has dropped a lot i
mean now you could open an account for
just you know
a few thousand dollars
commissions are very low
and you know it's it's almost as good as
you know the old days of being on the
floor with what people were paying
um in terms of rates i mean it's not as
good but it's good enough
so after i left the floor i joined edf
man the big english trading company in
chicago after that commerce bank
as the urex trader i traded buns bobble
shots then
after 9 11 i took some time off and you
know sort of toured around the world
went to go um you know southeast asia
and
eventually i wanted to get back in the
industry i joined cargill right the big
commodity trading company and i was
based in chicago
and you know i worked on the futures
trading desk there and eventually they
sent me out to singapore to set up a
trading desk when the
floor
of the cymex exchange the sgx exchange
was closing down and going fully
electronic
and you know i did that for about a year
then i joined jp morgan in singapore
where i was vice president of futures
trading and i left there in about 2013
because you know i was just tired of the
grind of working for another person i
know how to trade i could do it for
myself and you know i wanted to do more
in life
and that's when i started writing my
book on trading overflows now in 2015 i
started a software company called
order flows and the reason i'm just
talking about this now is because the
software that is used in this
presentation the tools that i use in
this presentation
are generated from my software but the
reason why i created the order flows
traders because the software that was
out there
you know wasn't necessarily built by
traders it was sort of built by
programmers
where
you know they would just see things out
there on the market and you know try to
use it but coming from the trading
background i know what i like to look
for in the order flow and i
said you know what the software should
do some of this analysis for me make my
life as a trader easier
okay so that's how i got into i sort of
fell backwards into the software
business because it originally was just
for my own personal use but then i was
sharing charts with other traders and
they're like hey what software is this
i'm like well it's my own and they're
like what can i get a copy and
eventually you know enough people was
asking that said you know what maybe um
you know maybe people really are
interested in the software
so again you know the software tools
that i use in this training are
generated from my software but what i'm
showing you can be used if you're using
you know other trading software trading
view is starting to add many of these
tools um sarah charts has them
um
you know tower a lot of the software out
there has them i think mine is the
easiest to use
but you're going to see how quickly
and easily you can apply order flow
analysis to your trading
and you know again
people ask me why do you do this you
know shouldn't you just concentrate on
training yeah i should but you know at
the same time i like to work with other
traders because i like to see people
improve themselves you know and you can
see you know other people are saying
about the software it's very helpful
because they can clearly see now what's
really happening in the market
all right so before i jump in you know
just a brief disclaimer
you know we're all adults here trading
involves risk so
you know big money right this is what
you call big money
it's not real but um in this case you
know i wish 100 bills were that big but
um
you know when people think of the terms
big money really what you're thinking of
is the big players in the markets right
so
if you could see where the big players
are buying and selling in the market do
you think it would be worth it to you to
trade in the same direction you know
this is just yesterday on bloomberg
commodity traders make record profits
right you know they still want to bail
out you know some of these firms you
know it's interesting because i think
shell
shell oil people you know just think of
you know these oil companies as
you know hedgers or you know users of of
oil actually they do a lot of prop
trading um as well you know goldman
sachs always you know record profits you
know they make the news once in a while
oh
profits are down you know so instead of
two and a half billion dollars they make
you know one and a half billion dollars
but they still make a lot of money so if
you could see the direction
and see what these guys are doing and
know how to read it in the market you
know that's something that should be
very very useful to you as a trader now
there is a way to see what they're doing
and that's by watching the order flow
and really what is order flow it's
volume traded at price
and this is an order flow chart okay
this is a what they call a footprint now
there's different ways to look at order
flow you can look at order flow from a
footprint chart which is what this is um
you can look at it from the dome the
depth of market you know because that
shows the bids and the offers that are
going in the limit
the limits um you know below the market
the limits above the market you know
orders that are pulled people say well
technically that's order flow
well it's not
real trades though what you're looking
on a footprint chart
actually traded right it shows people's
commitment
to the markets right if
you know just think of it yourself right
if you sell 10 shares of apple well
you have a vested interest in wanting to
see apple go down you're committed to
that trade right just like if you buy
tesla
you buy the tesla stock you're expecting
the market to go up
right you that's that's why you buy and
sell things and the same thing you know
in futures whether people buy or sell
e-minis you know mini dow nasdaq corn
wheat soybeans palm oil whatever
you know once they get into a trade
they're committed to the market you know
we could place orders all day long below
the bid above the offer
but if it doesn't trade there
we don't care if the market goes up or
down the rest of the day you know if
this market is trading you know 42
40 yeah i'd love to sell it at 42.45
when we're trading five points lower in
case the market spikes up or something
like that but i'm not going to get
filled at 42.45 when the market's
trading 4240. so
and that's one of the limitations of
looking at the depth of market of
looking at you know the the resting
liquidity it does provide insights
into certain aspects but you know basing
your trading on it
is
you know sort of basing your trading on
on whims
whereas when people are actually
committed to the market when people have
taken a trade it shows up in the volume
and it shows their commitment you know
the more they buy or sell the stronger
their commitment
now if you're looking at a normal
bar chart
right or candlestick chart
all you're really looking at is the open
the high the low and the close you're
not seeing what volume traded at price
you're not seeing if there was heavy
volume or light volume you're not seeing
if price was accepted or price was
rejected all you're seeing is the
open high low and close
and even that
leaves a lot to be desired as well
because
you know
where the market opens you know
especially if you're using a time based
chart
it's going to be where the previous bar
closed right i mean if you're using a
one minute chart market opens you know
market closes at 50 at 60 seconds and
the next bar opens right there okay
that's one of your data points on on a
candlestick chart you're high or low
people like to you know
judge the high or low on a candlestick
chart you know for certain patterns
but
that's actually the area that the least
amount of volume generally trades
and the close
okay close actually is sometimes
arbitrary right again based on time when
time expired okay that's where the
market closed
so you know that's some of the drawbacks
of just looking at a normal price based
charts
so
many trading strategies are based on the
premise that future prices are
determined by past prices
however when you're looking at the order
flow it's based on the premise that
future prices are determined by the
buying and selling pressure in the
market right now so really what is
overflow trading well
it's about trading based off of what the
other traders are doing right now you
know people love to use moving averages
okay well the problem with that is
you're
what happened
50 bars ago say it's a 50 period moving
average
50 bars ago 49 bars ago 48 bars ago
is affecting your decision right now
what you really want to be doing is
concentrating your decision off of
what's happening right now so for
example like yesterday one o'clock fed
announcement
market moved okay
do you think what happened if you're
using a moving average a 200 period
moving average a 50 moving average
do you think what happened at 8 30 in
the morning 9 o'clock in the morning 10
o'clock in the morning is going to be
affecting the market right now no
it's not going to have any effect
because now everyone's perception has
changed based off of
an external event
okay now order flow trading it can be
used in any market but it's especially
useful in markets that have centralized
price data futures is an example right
there's one exchange well more than one
exchange but the data gets routed
through the one exchange and
disseminated to the rest of the world
markets like forex
okay there's not one centralized
exchange so you're getting data from you
know different banks and
different sources right so
there's always going to be some
discrepancies
even to a certain extent crypto there's
you know 400 crypto markets out there
but if you stick with the big ones
obviously you know um
coinbase
finance you know get your data from
there you know it's pretty
representative of the overall market
um
stocks
you know if you're trading the big
stocks obviously you know you could have
good data sources available for that as
well
so by using
information about order flow traders can
get a feel for the direction of the
market and make better trading decisions
now this is
this morning here in
e-minis
and if you're looking at the
candlesticks you know again what
information is the chart really giving
you
you know it's telling you where the bar
opened and closed the high and the low
but it's not
giving you much more information you
don't know if prices were accepted up
here or rejected
you don't know you don't understand you
just see the market starting to trade
down and then you just okay well yeah i
got two red bars maybe i should go with
it well if you had two red bars here and
you went with it it just reversed back
up just like you had two green bars here
and then it reversed to green to red
to green again then it fell over right
you know shouldn't this be rallying but
it doesn't really give you much
information in terms of traders
actual intentions in the market
now the footprint chart gives you a lot
of information
right it's going to tell you
where the volume traded the most in a
bar right that's going to be your point
of control
it's going to tell you you know where
aggressive buyers or aggressive sellers
in control of the bar right that's going
to appear in the delta
right so if you have positive delta
aggressive buyers were in control you
have negative delta aggressive sellers
were in control of the bar
so that's going to tell you if the
market is in balance or out of balance
if it's
in balance
you're just going to have your normal
order flow going through if it's out of
balance you're going to see
buying imbalances or selling imbalances
and that's going to be highlighted
actually by in the volume in the bar
right buying advanced buying and
balances would be blue
selling and balances would be red okay
so again this is
the footprint chart
for this bar chart okay so what what can
i get from here well i know that we were
going sideways
it looked like we were sort of poking
higher
market traded a decent amount of volume
up here around the 4250-51 area but it
rejected that
value that volume up here started
trading down and then then it broke down
pretty quick as it was breaking down i
could see aggressive sellers right
through the delta
were getting stronger minus 183 so it's
telling me
aggressive sellers outnumbered
aggressive buyers by 183 in this bar
since it's negative
then minus 502 in the next bar minus
700.
so i know that now
instead of buyers and sellers being
roughly evenly matched
sellers are coming in more sellers are
coming in and even more sellers are
coming in because it's it's growing
whereas when you're going sideways you
see relatively smallish delta numbers 98
negative negative 74 positive 76 you
know 89
but now it's
picked aside right traders have picked a
side and they're looking to get short
you know and this is why the market was
still trading you know around 42 40 42
30.
you know where's that now 41 something
so let me ask you
right this is
this is yesterday before the fed
announcement um you know but this was a
great example right this market had been
trending up
okay then it sort of comes up here you
gotta ask yourself you know what would
you do
are you always going to be asking
yourself you know what would you do when
the market's going up you know are you
going to get ready to sell or you're
going to
stay long or you know get long and or
add on more to your long position
well
the market fell over right and it
basically
retraced that whole move up back down
here
but if you're looking up in here you
know was there really any reason to sell
on on a normal bar chart
not really
i mean you could be stretching and say
well yeah you know you had
three red candles four red candles um
you know
this is not really a rejection bar or
anything in terms of candlestick
patterns which i know people love
candlestick patterns because you know it
takes things and tries to make it give
some very colorful explanation
as to the pattern but you know it's not
particularly bearish even this bar right
here is kind of a bullish
candlestick pattern
but if you're looking at the order flow
what you're seeing in here was very
bearish
as you're coming up here right as you're
coming
up you're seeing
nice positive deltas it's even was
getting stronger you know 38
537 1078 the strongest delta right here
1078.
then the next bar
it decreases 172 so it's dropped about
80 percent in terms of volume
then the next bar is just 17. so imagine
you're rallying up
right and as the market rallies
it it feeds on itself right that's what
rallies do right there the higher prices
attract more buyers until the last buyer
has bought or sold and that's what
you're seeing up here is the last buyer
has bought
they're not interested really in buying
it anymore because
instead of going higher with stronger
positive delta it's just going sideways
with weaker positive delta
so it's showing signs of weakness up
here right up here as you just hit the
high and then you go sideways through
these two bars
and then obviously this bar right here
big negative delta so the sellers came
in now
now what are the clues are there
the point of control right the point of
control is the area with the most volume
in a bar and
you know in a basic sense
it's thought of as
sort of the fair value for that bar
so now you got the fair value of the bar
starting to move down right you have it
sort of peaking right here
in this red candle then the next candle
is lower obviously the next candle is
lower as well
lower
you know
two ticks higher and then lower
again and even in this bar right you've
got
is that seven selling imbalances okay
but
really what you're looking at is a
market that's transitioning
from
aggressive buying to aggressive selling
buyers
were interested buyers were here on this
move up
but then as you sort of peeked out
the buyers they
took us they took a step back but they
didn't have any more
bullets left so to speak right they
didn't have any more buying interest up
here and the market petered out couldn't
even go any higher than this high
and once you remove that buying pressure
from the market
right because the buying and selling
right is generally pretty even but what
drives markets is when you have more
buying
aggressive buying than aggressive
selling
and what that's what moves markets up
so if you have
aggressive buying and the market's still
moving up but it's getting lesser what
do you think is going to happen
well eventually it's going to stop it's
like when you drive your car right you
take your foot off the accelerator
eventually the car stops
and that's the end of it right just like
here
you know the buyers were here they're
interested but
they took their foot off the accelerator
so to speak
now in this case you still got selling
pressure going on because you know every
buyer there's a seller
and the sellers took over and drove the
market back down
now one of the most important concepts
for traders to understand is the
relationship between price and value
now in general price is a function of
value but the relationship between the
two is complex okay people often
misconstrue price
for value
and it's different right think of it you
know if you've ever watched those shows
um
i don't think it's still on anymore
american pickers you know the guys go
out and go out in the countryside and go
buy antiques then at the end of the show
like oh you know i made five thousand
dollars because i bought this sign for
a thousand dollars but i'm gonna value
it at five thousand dollars well
that's not really the real value the
real value is going to be when someone
buys it right
and you can put a price on something but
doesn't make it what it's worth right
it's really what it's worth is
when it's sells
right or someone buys it okay just like
the whole beanie baby thing you know
people oh you know beanie babies
this one's worth
three thousand dollars or something well
no it's worth five dollars unless
someone pays you three thousand dollars
for it
now once you understand that price and
value are two different things
start think of it in market terms so in
a trending or breakout environment right
a market that's trending or starting you
know a breakout would usually be the
beginning of a trend price is going to
lead value
in general okay price is searching for a
new level at which two-sided trading can
resume
now in a rotational environment
value is containing price so as price
starts to move away from value it will
come back
okay
and how do we see this in the order flow
well
you know most of
us traders we're familiar with we've
heard of the term market profile or
volume profile okay
you what the value area is in market
profile terms volume profile terms is
where i said 70 it's actually 70 percent
of the bar's volume traded over a
predetermined
period of time so for example right
today right s ps i took this chart
going back from the beginning of the day
you can see how the profile was looking
up until about nine o'clock right now
this is a volume profile it's not a
market profile very similar
now that's one way to look at
a volume profile now sort of the newer
ways over the last
20 years is to you can sort of break it
down
on shorter time frames so this is a
one minute chart with a
um
15 minute profile overlaid over it right
and so you can see how
the bars
are moving how the individual price is
moving on a minute by minute basis in
relation to
the
volume profile that's
developing you know as the market is
is trading and it's interesting you know
because you you start to see things that
you probably wouldn't have seen before
that are going to help you make greater
trading decisions
and what we've done with order flow
is
we've taken the footprint chart right
your normal footprint chart with the bid
offer volumes that are traded and all
the other information delta point
control imbalances
and we said
well
why don't we look at where the volume is
you know the let's say the volume but
rather the value is in a bar
right because in the past
order flow traders would use the point
of control as being
the default value in a bar but that's
just really one price level
okay and
you know a lot of bars trade
multiple price levels not every bar
trades
the bid or the offer right so it's like
saying you know picking one price as
being value you can't okay because the
value by definition would be you know 70
percent of
where the volume traded in the bar
so what we've done is we've added
the box around the profile a box around
the footprint to show
the value area
so you can see where
70 of the volume did trade in that bar
and you could sort of see relationships
to price as end volume
being the point of control where they
appear
in a bar
right because again
if
70 of the volume is the value right
again you could adjust it you know some
people say well it's really 68 percent
but 70 percent is or you know the
industry standard and you can start to
see how
value areas
get rejected
by the next bar
or the subsequent bars
and you can see how within a bar like
this red bar right here
price closes outside of value
right and if you've ever studied market
profile volume profile you understand
what that means when price starts moving
away from value it's trying to find a
new value area
and we've even taken a step further
and we have ways of highlighting value
areas on a bar by bar basis
that are important to traders
right because you can see how when the
market starts
moving away from value it can come right
back up to that value area
before continuing down how it's acting
as
resistance in this case
all right other times
it's going to act as support now this is
red candle
so it's going to be
resistance
you can see down here again this was
this morning right it's a great
opportunity to sell you know in the
4220s
8 you know
15 14 you know definitely above 42 10.
is it i mean the market had already been
selling off anyway but
it's just even if you're in a trade it
can help you
stay in the trade longer
right everyone always says oh you got to
let your winners run well by knowing
where value is and how price is trading
relative to value
that's how you're going to let your
winners run right everyone that's the
biggest
thing that everyone says cut your losses
short let your winners run but they
don't tell you how to do it
right it's about reading the market if
you're still seeing bearish order flow
coming in and you're short
you don't
get out of the trade now
you'll let it run you let it go as far
as you can
and
on a normal candlestick or bar chart
there's no volume information
more importantly there's no value area
information right this is that same move
right here
this
this is the first bar right
bar one here this is bar two okay
856 this one came in around what 903 so
you can see right here
all right that's the first bar
um what was it
it was this one here this was the second
bar
right
and you saw that yeah and the market
just sold off quite nicely i mean it's
going down now again it's not some
secret thing
this information is available out there
for traders it's whether or not they
want to use it you know it's not it's
not like oh you know like i got some
secrets i got whispered in your ear or
anything like that and don't tell
anybody else because you know what this
information is out there and i wish more
traders would use it because it would
make the moves even more powerful right
that's why i always laugh when i see
people say oh yeah i figured out a way
to trade the market but you know i don't
give away my edge well
if you're the only that's why edges
decrease over time
is
because they're transitory right you may
have found a discrepancy but over time
it's going to go away
you know but if you're using information
generated by the market
that's
provided by the market
it's not going to go away in that sense
right it's there
and again you know what information does
the candlestick give you well you can
see yeah you know i got this big wick up
here but all these candles got you know
big wicks
you know it starts breaking down here
but if you're looking at a footprint
chart
you know if you know how to read a
footprint chart you could see what was
happening you can see the delta getting
strong negative you can see the point of
control is going down
there's a few other things in here
you know there's a bearish selling tale
but simply look at the value
and you can see value is
starting to migrate lower right and what
was interesting is because now that i
know where value is
i know that i had sort of formed a
balance area in here and it looked like
it tried to break out of this balance
area and came right back into it
then the next bar the value area was
lower
and then even the next bar it didn't
even trade back into value now i know
we're moving away from value
and when you start to move away from
value
that's when the explosive moves are
going to happen
don't believe me
fed day yesterday right we all remember
that big rally it was a monster rally
look at this right i mean i know a lot
of traders saying uh you know this
market sucks because
it goes up two percent and goes down two
percent you know in the first 30 minutes
of trading um you know you can't make
heads or tails well that's because they
don't understand where value is
if you knew where value was
that low right here
at 136
right in here this bar this big green
bar
very bullish
and you can see that's where the move
started it came in right here after you
know it's training 75 afterwards and
then took off but based on this value
area and again you know i've scrunched
this chart down because it's such a big
move you can't read the numbers but you
don't necessarily need to focus on the
numbers you're focusing on where value
is
okay you can see how the market is
starting to move away from value it's
drawing out this area here so now i know
i got an area of support right and
right here and i know
when this bar is forming
that that support is forming i don't
need to have the market start breaking
out to new highs realize i got support i
have support
knowing where that support is
as it's happening
and confirmed within a minute
right while the market is still trading
right off these lows here
morning perfect example even before the
cash open and the big sell-off happened
i could see the value area here i could
see the value area starting to break
down
moving lower
right
you can see the gap in the two value
areas here i can see this
abandoned value area right here where
it's not even retracing back into it
then cache opened here
and then the move down big move down
happened right so this was those charts
i was showing you earlier this side
right here but it was actually starting
up
earlier than that
and
hey this morning um
yeah this was actually yesterday morning
not this morning
right ahead of the cash open we're
coming out of this sideways activity
this is a doji candle
and the market broke as soon as the cash
opened right and it was a move from you
know 80 down into 70.
sideways went back up
back up to 80 and back down to 70. but
these moves they happen
you know using value area is something
that just doesn't
have to be used during the us session
during european hours
every bar again every bar has a value
area so whether you're using it during
the us cash session
during the asian session it doesn't
matter
all you're really looking for is what's
happening in value is the market
starting to break away from value
right it's starting to break away here
started to break away here right this is
the european
session you know four in the morning
chicago time
asian hours
right this is about was that 21 40 was
that workout too
nine
9 40 p.m chicago time you know during
the the prime asian hours right
you get the same moves although albeit
smaller during the asian hours and
european session that you get during the
day usda session you look for the same
things
gold
again it doesn't matter what market
you're trading
whether it's e-minis
gold wheat corn palm oil
heating oil hogs
anyhow any any futures contract even
stocks
also have value areas the same analysis
can be applied to the stock market right
this is gold this morning right nice
moves
but you can see how we're moving away
from value
this is the euro currency futures now
this is this morning smaller rotations
because the market isn't as volatile as
the way stocks have been recently
but you know when volatility picks up
you're going to have bigger rotations
so remember
the
more intricate and complex the trading
methodology that you have where you
develop the more likely psychological
obstacles are going to develop and
hinder your trading and if you be can if
you become confused about the data or
find yourself unable to make decisions
inaction may seem like
the most rational option meaning if your
trading system
is a bit cumbersome and
complex
you're going to be second guessing
yourself you know whether you should be
taking a trade or not and you just end
up not taking the trade
now
trading successfully requires
taking calculated risks and making quick
decisions you know
a lot of times in trading you have to
make those quick decisions
you know you could even read
you know a big
history buff of of market history and
you can read the stories of you know the
guys from you know the crash in 87 even
the um
you know both on the cme and what
happened in singapore with the nikai
you know it's the guys that made that
quick decision
to buy
at the low that made a boatload of money
right that trading revolve
often involves especially intraday
trading
quick
decisions and when i talk about trading
though my style of trading is intraday
trading i'm not a swing trader where i
could sit back over the weekend and find
you know a stock
while i'm sipping my brandy or something
like that no i i in and out during the
day i'm done at the end of the day so
simple and obvious is always better than
complex and convoluted order flow is the
simple and obvious way so
over the last 45 minutes or so
hopefully you'll agree it's been time
well spent right but honestly i can't
cover everything in a quick training
session you know
order flow is so unique
there's so much information available to
traders you know in terms of aggressive
buyers aggressive sellers imbalances in
the markets
you know
just volume analysis you know is
is something that
takes a lot of time to
learn and explain you know because
there's so many different little nuances
right it's not like
you can figure out trading in one
afternoon
you know it you always got to be
improving i said i've been involved in
the markets for over 30 years now and
i'm always looking for new ways to view
the market or improve my trading
now i've got a special offer
so you get everything you need to know
about order flow
and if you act fast i got a very very
special deal so it's the order flows
trader software right the software that
you saw in this presentation
i mean again you don't necessarily need
my software if you have some software
you gotta cobble together the pieces
and put it together but you know it's
nice to have everything in one software
and it's like taking my
knowledge of trading order flow and put
it into a program so you can see what
institutional traders are doing in the
market because after all i was an
institutional trader for over 20 years
but having overflow software is one
thing you still need to know how to use
it
right i mean you know a lot of times you
know you buy software
and it's just like okay you paid the
money and now you got to sort of figure
out on your own how to use it i just
don't give you the software and send you
on your way
for you to sort of
go down the rabbit hole try to figure it
out you know what certain settings meet
i provide a lot of education on how to
trade with order flow i'll give you
access to my order flow trading course
so you know
what everything means in the order flow
and you know what to look for in the
order flow normally i sell it for 297
dollars you can get it for free
but
i realize you know if you're interested
in order flow you really want to go to
the next level and you want to go fast
right
well we all like to move as quick as
possible
and so i have my order flow inner circle
video series which is a collection of 56
videos
on advanced order flow tricks tips of an
analysis i'll give you access to that
actually you know you can't even buy it
off the shelf anymore you know you can
only get it through this package and
all this together you know the software
normally sell for 900 the training 297
the inner circles another 497. that's
already 1600 almost 1700
but i realize it's one thing to learn
from videos and books right that
actually takes a lot of commitment and
discipline you know when i was in
college i had i i thought i stumbled on
the greatest course you know it was a
history course
where
you do all the studying you don't go to
class you just read the book and you
take three tests
um within the semester
and i thought this is easy and yeah i
never really did the studying right i
never really did the learning and i just
barely passed
the class but
what i've found more useful especially
in trading is live
training sessions right where
you could ask questions you know what
did you see what were you thinking on
this trade or even send me in you know a
chart that you marked up and you know i
could take a look at it and it's live
you know i'm there every week i've been
doing this for over three years
it's every tuesday night
from 7 pm to 8 pm and if you can't
attend
then
you could watch the replay right just
make sure you sign up you'll get access
to the replay
so and it's free for all the users of
the software you know i've done over 100
here it says 157 it's over 160 now
and you know many of these gurus out
there
want to charge you extra you know i've
seen people charge up to 200 a month
for training
on how to use their software i mean what
i don't get it what's up with that right
if you're
making an investment on buying a
software to help your trading
you know you
you want some instruction on it
right again you know i've seen
other
vendors out there you know okay i'll
charge you just 59 a month for the
software then you know but you know all
you want training okay that's uh that's
a thousand dollars
what's up with that you know at least
this way you know you have a way to
reach me
every tuesday night i'm there right it's
interactive
lots of times it's just me lecturing i i
wish
you know people would ask more questions
but still um it is what it is and you
can you you can join you can ask your
questions or you can just sit back and
watch and maybe you just got one
question i know sometimes people are a
little shy
but it's there for everybody and what i
discussed today is just a sample of the
forms of analysis i talk about weekly
and what's available in the inner circle
video series
you're going to learn more about order
flow in the weekly sessions than you
thought possible honestly you know it's
it's
again you know you can watch videos you
know and there's a lot of videos out
there that i've recorded that other
people have recorded you know over the
years but really what you want is the
current stuff right what are we seeing
in the markets right now because you
know what the markets are dynamic what
the market you're looking at today is
different than it was three years ago
different than it was five years ago
so to get started go to orderflows.com
i put the link in the chat
there
so you know where to get it from
and basically takes you to this page all
you do is you scroll down to the bottom
of the page there's some videos you know
if you want to learn more about the
software you can watch it
and
after you do that right it's going to
take you to the buy button down here you
just click on that button
right and you can see what you're going
to get you're going to get the order
flows trader software
trading courses access to the live
weekly group trainings
and i got a special bonus which i'll
talk about in a second so you just click
on that button
and it takes you to paypal okay now it
takes it takes some time for paypal to
process your information and for us to
generate all your user logins and and
everything
um
you know we try to be as quick as
possible but it can sometimes it could
take a few hours but you know you should
get it relatively soon and just bear in
mind everything is sent to your paypal
registered email address okay so
make sure you check your spam folder and
if you haven't updated your paypal email
address
you should um
because that's where it's all sent to
and again if you don't get it within you
know five six hours just drop me an
email
and again it's just a one-time payment
of 749 so you're not paying
sixteen hundred dollars
seventeen hundred dollars for it's just
seven forty nine right you're saving
over a thousand dollars
so go to orderflows.com5.html
there's no more recurring payments
there's no more
um
other payments in the future you know
like after you know yearly people sell a
yearly software then a year later you
get a charge you call the message from
your bank oh you know you're
you're overdraft because they snuck in a
new payment for thousand dollars or
something for their software no this is
just a one-time payment um now you will
need to pay your data fees
right and your ninja trader fees if
because my software runs on ninjatrader
8.
as a special bonus i'll give you access
to the order flow playbook which is a
trading course
a more advanced trading course on order
flow and in it i even discuss an
additional 10 or 11 trade setups that
you can look for because again you know
the order flow
information is so robust there's a lot
of different ways to look at it and
really if you're using order flow you
need to know what to look for
trying to figure it on out on your own
it's going to cost you a lot of time and
more importantly it's going to cost you
a lot of money and normally i sell that
for 297 dollars but you're going to get
it for free
okay so you're going to be getting a lot
of stuff here go to orderflows.com
so you're going to get the order flows
trader
5.0 which is the current version
it's valued at 8.99 and access to the
order flow trading course which is the
values 297.
the order flows inner circle video
series which is worth 4.97
you're going to be able to join the live
weekly group trainings
again you know i don't know i put a
price on that but yeah it to me that
that's
the best way to get up to speed as
quickly as possible
and you can access the order full
playbook you get all that for just a
one-time payment of 7.49 now if you
stuck around
and you want my book
go to
dot orderflows.combook.htm you have to
write the dot html afterwards and i'll
take you to the page just enter your
name and email address and hit submit
and it'll take you to a page with
another video on it as well as the book
on it that you can download again it's a
digital download you're not going to get
the hard copy book
so get started you go to orderflows.com
now again you know it's what year are we
2022. it's may already my goodness this
year is flying by
and
you got several options you could do
nothing
that's fine you know don't twist your
arm you stay right where you are
right now
and you know you just you think you're
going to become a better trader by
yourself
okay there's nothing wrong with that but
you know it
it takes a big commitment on your part
or two
you can take what you learned here today
watch more my videos other traders
videos
and
do a lot of trial and error
you know and after a few months maybe
you're lucky maybe you start to see some
positive results
maybe you don't realize what you're
doing the mistakes that you're making
and you know it was a bit of
luck
or maybe you know you did pick it up i
mean some people are able to pick it up
by watching videos and reading books but
the best way to do it is
allow us to take you by the hand and
walk you step by step through each part
of the process skip that trial and error
part right because
the worst thing you're going to do is
not just lose the time but lose money
right time it you know they say time is
money but
you know if you're have no
money you know all you got is time
that's one thing but i'd rather have
more money in my pocket than time i
don't know that's just me but if you do
the work
right if we work together
you'll watch as your life and trading
transforms right before your eyes so
figure out which option is best for you
so again get started by going to
orderflows.com
slash off five and again i put
everything in the
chat for the book
as well as to get the software
um
yeah i got some time here i'll just go
through a couple minutes a couple
questions really quick here
um
how long is the offer good for
it's good for a while i mean honestly
i've had it at this price
since colbit hit and i haven't changed
it
can it be used for trading with options
well
i trade futures i'm a futures guy you
know i'm from chicago
obviously got the big futures exchanges
in chicago
that's where i worked that's my
background can you use it with options
i i don't use it with options i don't
know if anybody does i haven't met any
trader specifically that trades options
i know i have users that also trade
options i don't know how they've
incorporated in there i i haven't asked
i don't use ninjatrader
is the training unbundled and still of
value you know what if you have other
software if you have sierra charts you
know because i have people that buy my
training right if you go to my website
you go to orderflows.com
there's a link for the
training like the the order flow
trading course and
if you buy that i do
include a few of the other courses like
the um
playbook and a few other ones so
i i there are users that have
just bought the train because they
already have order flow software either
through sierra charts or um
atas or something
and you know a few of the other ones and
they just really wanted to get up to
speed on order flow without making that
jump into ninjatrader so you can you can
get the courses by themselves
on my website
now so the first question here does the
approach work on for swing trading
it
okay swing trading it depends you know
i've meet swing traders who are intraday
swing traders and i meet
swing traders that are
you know more longer term meaning you
know a day or two or three or even
longer order flow is best used
on an intraday basis on a short time
frame
okay because
you know what happens in the market
right now affects what's going to happen
in the next
few bars right i mean sometimes you know
beginnings of trends it helps you find
but
again you know sometimes finding
something in the order flow like
yesterday right at the fed
um
after you know 30 minutes after the fed
announcement you know market reversed
and went up and the signs were there in
the order flow
okay
now
that's not to say that that trend is
going to go to infinity obviously you
still need to read the order flow as
it's as it goes looking for that
confirmation or looking for things that
have changed in the order flow to become
bearish
okay like this morning right the market
was
pretty quiet you know a little bit quite
you know a bit scary and overnight how
quiet it was i think people were in a
bit of shock uh um on a big rally
yesterday but then this morning it's
become very bearish
okay now
you know my time frame is just
you know intraday i i rarely hold trades
for more than
an hour so can you use it for swing
trading yeah if you're more of a shorter
term swing trader an intraday swing
trader if you're someone that's going to
be holding it for two or three days you
know probably not
right i mean like that bottom yesterday
at 1 36
in the afternoon
you know by the end of the day
it's you know the overflow is done for
the day you know now you got to reassess
it for the next day so i don't know if
that answers your question or not so all
right everybody thanks for attending
and i'm happy to uh
answer your questions um trader
the page doesn't allow you to fill in
your name to download the book
it should i just checked it earlier
actually but um
if you're having a problem downloading
the book
i'll just write something here in the
chat for you
so email me
it's just mike order flows.com you know
put something in the subject line like
um i want your book or something and
i'll just reply to you with the link so
all right everybody thanks for coming
and thanks for taking the the time out
of this day you know today was a very uh
strong moving day so it's time to get
back to the market so thanks everybody
and i'll see you guys later bye-bye
you